hi everyone I am M and welcome to this
fantastic video on decision trees in
machine learning by simply Lear if you
enjoy watching these type of videos and
find them interesting subscribe to our
YouTube channel as we bring the best
videos daily also hit the Bell icon to
never miss any update from Simply learn
in this video we will discuss what is a
decision tree after that we will see the
advantages of using decision Tre then
decision tree applications and and how a
decision tree works at the end we will
see Hands-On lab demo of how you can
build a decision tree classifier before
moving on to what the decision tree is
if you want to become an AI expert and
gain handsome salary packages look at
the wide range of AIML courses by simply
learn in collaboration with top
universities across the globe by
enrolling in any of these certification
program you will gain expertise in
skills like generative AI prompt
engineering Char gity explainable AI
machine learning algorithm supervis and
unsupervised learning model training and
optimization and there is much more on
the list with hands-on experience in
tools like chat GB d python CV open CV
and tensorflow you will catch the eye of
top recruiters so what are you waiting
for hurry up and enroll now a year of
experience is prefer to enroll in these
courses find the course Link in the
description box below with that in mind
let's get started so what is a decision
tree a decision tree is a tree based
supervised learning method used to
predict the output of a Target variable
decis ision tree python can be used to
solve classification and regression
problem they are frequently used to
determine odds this is an example of a
simple decision tree used to classify
different animal based on their feature
moving forward let's see advantages of
using decision tree so first one is
decision trees are simple to understand
interpret and visualize the second one
is they can effectively handle both
numerical and categorical data the third
one is they can determine the worst best
and expected values for several scenario
the fourth one is decis trees require
little data preparation and data
normalization moving forward let's see
some decision Tree application the first
one is a decision tree determines
whether an applicant will likely default
on a loan the second one is it can be
used to determine the odds of an
individual developing a specific disease
the third one is it can help e-commerce
companies predict whether a consumer is
likely to purchase a specific product or
not the fourth one is decision Tre can
also be used to find customer churn rate
so now let's see how does a decision
tree work Suppose there are different
animals and you want to identify each
animals and classify them based on their
feature we can easily accomplish this by
using a decision tree the following is a
clutter sample set with a high entropy
right we have to determine which feature
split the data so that the Information
Gain is the highest we can do that by
splitting the data using each feature
and checking the Information Gain that
we obtain from them the feature that
Returns the highest gain will be used
for the first split so we will take some
following feature into consideration
color height and the diameter we will
use the Information Gain method to
identify which variables eals the
maximum gain which can also be used as a
root node suppose we take color equals
to Yellow result in the maximum
Information Gain so that is what we will
use for our first split at root node the
entropy after splitting should decrease
considerably however we still need to
split the child node at the both
branches to attain the entropy value
equals to zero so we will split the both
nodes using the height variable and the
height is greater than 10 or height is
less than 10 as our condition so as you
can see the decision tree can now
predict all the animals classes in the
data set moving forward let's implement
the hands on so this is our jupyter
notebook screen first we will change to
decision this ision
Tre so first we will import some some
the required libraries here so I will
import pandas as
PD then I will
import M plot
lip.
pyplot as
PLT then I will import from my skan
import
Matrix because you create Matrix and
then I will
import
cbor as
SNS then from
sk. data
sets
import import
load Isis
right okay oh one more
import P sorry n by as
NB then I will import some from
skn
modore
selection import
Trainor testore
split then I will import from
skar
import three right let me run it
okay so now pandas is a python library
that provid fast powerful flexible and
easy to use data analysis and
manipulation tools whether numai is a
python library for Python programming
language adding support to large
multi-dimensional arrays and matrices
along with a large collection of high
level mathematical function to operate
on these are okay
so fine yes and the M plot mat plot is a
plotting library for Python programming
language and its numerical mathematics
extension num it provides an
objectoriented API for embedding plots
into application using general purpose
GUI toolkits like Tinker wxpython qt or
gt and a cbone cbone is a library for
making statical Graphics in Python it
builds on top of M plot Li and
integrates closely with pandas and data
structures cbon also helps you to
explore and understand your data right
so now what I will do I will
import sorry not import I will write
here Iris equals to
load
is
right okay if I will write here Iris it
will okay as you can see the array you
can see here okay Iris AR
right so here uh I will convert the data
into P data frame so for that I will
write data equals to PD do data
Frame data frame or DF you can write
data equals
Tois
data
columns to Iris do
feature
names right so now moving forward what
we will do we will create a separate
column for the Target variable of the is
data right so Target variable will be
our species so for that I will write
here
data
species equals to RIS
do Target
right and moving forward what I will do
I will replace the categories of the
target variable with the actual name of
the spaces so for that I will write
Target
equals to NP do
unique Isis
dot
Target and
Target
nals to NP
do
unique
then
iris. Target names right then I will
write here Target
underscore directory
to direct
zip then Target comma Target
n right then
data
species equals to S will be
capital
data
species
replace Target
Dory right let me run it it's working
fine so now what I will do I did uh I
replace the categories of Target
variable with the actual names of the
spes right so now what we will do we
will separate the IND dependent and the
dependent variables of the data set okay
so for
that I have to write here xal to data do
drop
columns plus to
species right then yal to
data
species then names underscore features
= to X
do
columns then Target
labels to Y do
unique
fine so now what we will do we will
split the data set into training and the
testing data set right and we'll set
some random State okay so for
that before let me add
this okay so here I will add xcore
train comma
xcore test comma Yore
train Yore
test to
train test
split X comma
y
comma test size = to
0.3
comma random
state to
93 so what is this 0.3 what it will do
it will split the training and the
testing size into 30 and the 70% see 0.3
17 to 30% right so training will be 70%
and the testing will be on the 30% of
the data set this data set fine as you
can see the uh the class name
this okay so moving forward what we what
we will do we will import the decision
classifier class from the Escalon right
so here from Escalon do tree
import decision
tree
classifier okay so now what we will do
we will uh create an instance of a
classifier class so you can use your
DTC
to decision three classifier
maxcore depth = to 3 comma
random State =
right so now let's fit the train
training dat set to the model so
DTC DTC means decision classifier right
D
fit xcore
train comma Yore
train okay X train
is not
defined there is
Extreme
okay maybe some spelling mistake I don't
think so
so it was a typ of mistake to here decis
three classifi G right so now let's plot
the decision Tre okay so pl.
figure figure
size = to 30 comma
10 and the face
color will be yellow let's take a look
later we change okay then Tre equals to
Tre Dot Plot _ Tre then DC
comma
feature
names equals
to names underscore
features Comm
class names
then equals to Target
labels comma round
itals to
True
right so let me give the font size two
comma font
size of
16 fine I get 16 is fine so now uh let
me write
PLT Dosh
show okay then
Yore
prediction to
DTC
doed xcore test
right okay T three okay here class name
it
is more error okay method object is non
uh not
subscriptable
okay so here see
Capital again some method object
is so it was the kernel error so let's
here find the confusion Matrix so here I
will write
confusion
Matrix equals
to Matrix dot
confusion
underscore Matrix then Yore test Yore
prediction right so here I will write
Matrix to PD do data
Frame data frame then
confusion let go
Matrix right so here I will write
XIs = to PLT dot
AIS right then SNS do
set font
scale = to
1.3 then PLT do
figure then figure
size equal
to 10
comma
7 right so now let's plot the heat maps
for that I will write heat map SNS do
heat
map so Matrix comma an
not equals
toal to
true then
fmt + 2
G Comm ax
= to AIS comma cmap =
to
magma right so for that
XIs do set
_
title then I will write here confusion
Matrix right then XIs dot
set
X
label here I will write prediction
predicted
value then font
size equ to
10 then XIs do
set xtick value pick
labels
here I will write plus
Target Target
labels right then access.
set y
labels y
label then I will write here
true
labels font
size
will be
XIs dot set y t
levels
y t
labels then it will be list of targeted
values Target labels comma
rotations will be zero right and at the
end I will write PLT do show Okay so
let's
run so as you can see here it created
the decision tree right so these so
these are the ches and the leaf notes
these all are the notes right of the
different
different versy color you can see SATA
Seda Vin right with the different
different you know samples okay with the
accuracy so this is the confusion Matrix
of this particular graph here uh you can
see here the true labels and the
predicted values of the particular graph
right this is the confusion metric so
and with that so we have come to end of
this video on decision 3 with machine
learning I hope you found it valuable
and entertaining please ask any question
about the topics covered in this video
in the comment section below our experts
will assist you in addressing your
problems thank you for watching stay
safe and keep learning with simply learn
staying ahead in your career requires
continuous learning and upskilling
whether you're a student aiming to learn
today's top skills or a working
professional looking to advance your
career we've got you covered explore our
impressive catalog of certification
programs in cuttingedge domains
including data science cloud computing
cyber security AI machine learning or
digital marketing design in
collaboration with leading universities
and top corporations and delivered by
industry experts choose any of our
programs and set yourself on the path to
Career Success click the link in the
description to know
more hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simply learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos to nerd up and get certified
click here